as you can see like the generosity is
is uh amazing um within this
organization and
and for the community so we saw how
special was to help everyone on
on thanksgiving and and pass out food
and turkeys so
being able to come back now is just as
rewarding and
you know it's always throughout my
13-year career it's always been the same
you always
feel good around the holidays when you
help give back and credit you know kim
frank and her team for
uh you know setting this up and always
you know being one step ahead with that
you know helping out our community as as
the team always has and
um just putting our best foot forward to
help everyone around the holidays
it's very special and i mean obviously
as as everyone knows uh
the team is heavily involved with
community and and you know we like to to
get out and
interact with our fans in the community
and and the city that supports us you
know every single night
um you know down at t-mobile and even
fans you know away from the city all
over the country so
you know it's very special and we're
honored and to be able to come down here
and
help out around the holidays